yes Luanne to welcome to this video
playing a water beta from Germany yeah
it's an interesting thing what a bitter
what is that in English I have no idea
what this is it's a food yeah I mean
it's a food and it's red right like it's
not right Beach be sure it's not that I
don't know maybe someone can look it out
i don't want to do it during the game he
plays the london system with the bishop
would be fire food and I had this I hate
this kind of but after the capture
against international must again if
mines interesting yeah he wants to fight
for the dark squares I guess maybe
taking taking on c6 and to lay tonight
be three or so I know he has to Castle
though probably know well okay this also
possible every Bishop a6 as an idea and
and he prevented Bishop a6 here with
this move as well Quincy six is
something that is a double attack
basically then you take cake and then c5
I still has screen sir sex okay we ate
is an attack on the beep answer what I
want to avoid us to get into this
structure with the night coming to see 5
i've got this one
that's stupid yes no I overlooked this
again and now I'm in some trouble it's
quite difficult to get into trouble
against the London that you can manage
okay for Bishop a6 business ok Bishop a
six now already looks like maybe some
compensation well it can take Adam can
take this bishop you can take the bishop
I can I can take 13 first okay I was
thinking that takes never forget was
what to say it's it's okay be sure
basics one thing that I was becoming
aware we said he has potentially some
queen bee three to attack aged seven
that made and and the book that it's
useless he cannot take on a kid he takes
on a six I take 183 so okay would it be
too what are you doing
and we cannot cancel it's not so easy i
mean the rukon h1 does something but
someone ideal yep okay Peverley heading
towards reform
okay so i would like to okay maybe f3 is
his intention here very likely even huh
it's not easy to activate him not easy
at all he has 96 I really didn't look at
smoke maybe you could have played at her
I mean night before maybe maybe probably
not not really that was my idea it's not
doing all that much you can put the
night back check on b2 doesn't work my
background is weak I have to be a little
bit cautious yes Queen 7ss move for him
maybe
cliff space down just preventing Luke c8
okay it's not so easy for me to remain
sir bit of a nuisance to defend so he
wants to enter them yo so I take a
look-see to as it is extremely dangerous
I cannot allow them to take ray mmm it's
a bit of a problem huh I 96 I really
have to stop the session and I'm
overlooking the simplest smooth over
here he doesn't play it
[Music]
positions still sucks i'm horny
extremely whatever it's bad anyway
rook takes be to now is a threat some
whatever threat
she goes Luke a six I don't really have
a good move and now I take it I somehow
it's not making any progress to put it
mildly not trading here with the King
being somewhat unsaved check check
skimming the plants lots of phones and
this guy is that she's checking me okay
wow what the frigging freak
25 I don't know what what was that 25
check like four feet long time wow I was
still very scary at the end I had off
did I screw it up maybe I did yeah I
mean he had multiple ways to win really
multiple ways yeah then I really played
bad layer this all only really makes
sense that i can get see feiven and okay
look be a droopy 69 bishop a six by the
comp now I just I just didn't sequin III
I was really really bad I was this is
just totally just totally sucks and then
probably also didn't help I get the
night in yet 96 more than once I mean
and he never played it for some reason
here did this just win stuff we have no
it's nothing going on but ok he still
has a huge advantage yeah i blundered
the exchange again here I a 96 ok ok I
didn't want to change yeah well ok this
is something that I actually saw but if
I thought he can take here and now we're
ends Luc g7 but made but computer just
place this because you can go here
hahaha and no I did not consider this
[Laughter]
and this is the drawing line no it's not
a draw what is drawing look G c7 is it
all with 94 yes this doesn't work or
what that's completely crazy and nobody
plays like that a 96 again somehow I
never wanted to play that I mean I was
lost so often in this game this is was
the first time I'm somewhat in the game
after he gifted me those to tempe can't
yeah I know things can shift in my
favorite I was still a big scare that
the end of stage is made and just around
the corner 98 no possible to play here
they actually saw that he can take it
but I just wanted some space didn't take
it this yeah actually make sure you save
well I was an extremely lucky when I was
lost for ya ninety-five percent of this
game or so ok guys thanks for watching